[Musique]
haha
allez mais dans une chicha de banlieue
dans lequel mon pierrot enfin je dois
faire un showcase et il a été chercher
la protection du rappeur la crime sauf
que dès que la crimée partie la violence
a repris ses droits
ne cherchez pas la victime dans la série
c'est moi qui va alors tu souris mois
sans voir ce qu'on va faire travailler
mon acolyte de toujours va se faire
casser la gueule par un baiser par mon
ennemi juré carnage dépêche toi pour son
bon sens autant qu'aux médias pour moi
c'est maquillage c'est mesure où je fais
voler ses cascades aussi voilà ça c'est
bien ça me prend ça mais craque donc le
lavabo la fin ils sont jeunes ils sont 5
si ça va mettre découdre en levant la
tête et touche les eaux les frères
louret du secteur aurait pas de lecteur
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé près
là c'est la furie total et valait 1 je
suis boxeur mois donc du coup j'ai pas
de problème avec ça
après
auxerre n'a ravi bossard cinéma c'est
plutôt très excitant tourner des scènes
comme ça en fait
et là les garçons ils ont kiffé je vous
rassemble c'est ça se voit l'image on
assume on parle d'un des lieux dans
lequel la violence existe c'est vrai il
ya des embrouilles entre rappeurs qui
ont été extrêmement médiatisé comme tout
le monde s'est alors là c'est violent ce
film est relayée et puis toute la
violence dans le grand public et pas au
courant et qui existe de manière assez
importante alors évidemment il ya
certains rappeurs qui sont moins touchés
que d'autres par ça parce qu'ils
viennent pas des mêmes milieux qui n'ont
pas les mêmes relations
mais bon comme toi mais enfin le rap dur
c'est pas un milieu de bisounours
donc oui à la testostérone il ya des
rivalités il ya de la jalousie et tout
ça entraîne parfois de la violence et
toute une réalité que qu'il fallait que
je traite quoi et puis au delà de ça qui
est plutôt cinématographique à fumer en
plus value d une création originale à
découvrir en avant-première en ce moment
sur my canal